je pense qu'il est très important de
dire que les apparitions de la vierge
marie et du christ sont beaucoup plus
fréquentes qu'on veut bientôt
la pendaison j'ai vu la vierge de liévin
moi comme ça qu'on joue avec landreau
jésus il matto n avait comme voyais un
voile blanc
il avait une brise et son voile ou
plutôt son manteau bougeait c'était
comme une image qui apparaissaient et
disparaissaient entre les plantes les
gens qui y est c'est impressionnant y
voyais un million 1 dont ils ont des
grands spécial mais ça reste des êtres
humains pour en faire des idoles bagot
offre des jeux voilà virgin en trois
dimensions c'est à dire que je la vois
comme je vous vois je parle avec elle
comme je parle avec vous et je peut la
toucher aussi
je crois que la science a des limites
beaucoup de gens sont mal aimés ils
savent que par elles au moins ils sont
aimés c'est la recherche d'une immense
personnalité féminine
à
bonjour tout le monde
nous avons
le chemin des genres depuis notre départ
de dorval à montréal c'était il ya
presque vingt quatre heures
nous voilà presque rendu à medjugorje
alors j'aimerais qu'on commence
véritablement notre pèlerinage par la
prière
du chapelet et le chant
de produits de rentrer à paris mais non
c'est arrivé
dieu vrillé bon
thomas à metz au
ap
ah ah
allez allez
depuis vingt ans les pèlerins
catholiques se pressent par millions
dans ce petit village au pied des
collines d'herbe et gobine en ex
yougoslavie medjugorje la vierge marie
dit on serait apparu pour la première
fois le 24 juin 1981 à six habitants du
village depuis tous les jours la vierge
continuerait de leur apparaître la mère
du christ ce serait donc manifester à
cet endroit plus de 7000 fois de toute
l'histoire du christianisme c'est de
très loin la plus longue suite
ininterrompue l'apparition chaque jour
plusieurs milliers de pèlerins venus
d'amérique d'europe d'asie ou des
antilles viennent assister à la messe
dans ce village qu'il considère touché
par la grâce de dieu parmi les six
voyant comme on les appelle plusieurs
continuent de vivre au village
maria ivan participent à la vie de la
paroisse saint-jacques de medjugorje et
interviennent régulièrement à la messe
m
tout commence durant l'été 1981 six
adolescents âgés de 11 à 17 ans quatre
filles et deux garçons affirment voir la
vierge marie sur une colline dans le
village ils sont les seuls témoins
visuels de cette manifestation
nous sommes un an après la mort de tito
dix ans avant le début de la guerre en
yougoslavie et la vierge de medjugorje
se fait appeler la reine de la paix
oui
non
alors ce jour là meliana là et ivanka
les deux vont être là en attendant vite
qu'un et à un moment donné dans
l'après-midi vers 5 heures de
l'après-midi le 24 juin 1981 ivanka
tournoux son regard vers la colline et
dit à l'autre mais c'est la vierge
l'autre fille sa copine c'est à dire
mirjana une fille de ville de sarajevo
elle va dire mais doit quoi tu parles
qui elle vierge
ça se peut pas que la vierge leur
apparaissent
cette nuit là rares sont ceux qui ont
dormi
vraiment
le lendemain le 25 juin 1980 vers 18
heures les deux adolescentes remonte à
la colline avec quatre camarades
cette fois tous les 6 10 voire la gospa
la dame comme on l'appelle ici et depuis
ce jour là yaacov mois mirjana vichy cas
et ivan nous avons commencé à voir la
paris sont tous les jours au début nous
avions peur parce que nous ne savions
pas qui c'était même si dans nos coeurs
nous savions que c'était la scène vierge
la grand-mère de wisches cas a dit
prenez de lou bennett aspergé
l'apparition de besné existe si tu es de
dieu reste et si tu n'aimes pas de dieu
vat ans et à cet instant la vierge a
souri et elle a dit qu'elle était la
mère de dieu et qu'elle était venu ici
parce qu'elle avait trouvé la foi ici je
vois la vierge en trois dimensions c'est
à dire que je la vois quand je vous vois
je parle avec elle comme je parle avec
vous et je peut la toucher aussi
on a mal au moment où gastronomie deux
vols et puis peu à peu la vierge nous a
permis de l'embrasser à certaines
occasions pour nos anniversaires
en fait quand nous voyons la vierge elle
est toujours vêtue d'une longue robe
grise d'un long voile blanc hélas les
cheveux noirs les yeux bleus et se tient
debout sur un nuage et elle a une
couronne des toiles autour de la tête
c'est à dire que nous voyons la vierge
comme toute autre personne
souvent les enfants interviennent au
début de l'apparition
ce sont les producteurs du premier souci
parce que dans la religion chrétienne il
personnalise l'innocence donc la parole
dit par un enfant est plus crédible
qu'une parole émise par un adulte
mais dans la phase suivante c'est
l'église locale qui intervient en
acceptant ou refusant la parole des
enfants
donc il est vrai que les enfants sont
importants mais seulement dans la phase
initiale après celle autorités
religieuses qui légitimise ou non cette
vérité vous savez que la pratique
religieuse durant toute cette période de
dictature communiste a été interdite
mais alors parler des apparitions
c'était impensable pour les autorités
communistes
donc ils ont commencé tout de suite à
persécuter les enfants à persécuter le
village et à persécuter les franciscains
en passant que c'est les franciscains
qui aurait tout inventé
pour empêcher les apparitions la police
communiste décide de bloquer l'accès à
la codim le curé du village un frère
franciscain invite alors les enfants à
se réfugier dans l'église désormais leur
apparition quotidienne aura lieu dans la
chapelle
pendant l'office du soir vers 18h15
depuis le début des apparitions
chaque matin les pèlerins vont écouter
la voyante bichat yvan covic parmi les
voyants vie chat est la seule
célibataire elle consacre toutes ces
matinées à délivrer les messages qu'elle
dit avoir reçus de marie la vierge leur
ai montré le purgatoire et les enfers et
aurait demandé à wisches cas d'avertir
le monde des dangers que satan lui fait
courir
elle appelle les hommes à se tourner
vers dieu avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
bien risque a pas parlé dans quelques
minutes et ils étaient 1 pourrait
traduire en français ça a été difficile
de se faufiler
oui alors on attendait patiemment son
message
m
battles et sa déprime chez palais que la
mère de la victime
c'est le paigc et les messages précis
book en ariège nous donne ce sont la
prière et papiers la paix connaissiez la
conversion confié la confession did you
know et le je veux qu'elle me donne est
recommandé que les jets pm petit pas que
zahia aussi la vierge nous le commande
de prier à chaque jour le razr de milan
n'a rien avec jésus-christ qui les
peuplent le suivait c'est la même chose
m
et
chanter un manque de tolérance puis moi
ça me faisait de la peine parce que j'ai
l'impression que mes seins qui sport
elle aussi ça il fait de la peine ce
procès qui a vu avec ont conçu nice
convives en amour convives dans la paix
donc pour que france bouscule qu'ils
aient les moyens bouillon 1 dont ils ont
des grands spécial mais c'est ça reste
des êtres humains faut pas en faire des
idoles vraiment et ne vit pas pour elle
moi je la considère très très haut dans
la sainteté nous seulement une personne
totalement données qui se donne
totalement mais une personne qui a eu
aussi des épreuves de souffrances
multiples n'aime pas les dire ma femme y
en a qu'on devine enfin ce qu'on appelle
une âme victimes viennent pas beaucoup
ce terme un visa est dramatique mais il
ya des gens qui comme le cric fin comme
le christ a souffert la passion il nous
a sauvés en passant par la passion il ya
des gens qui sont appelés à subir les
mêmes épreuves
et pour moi ce n'est qu'à 10 juin
l'imposition des mains par les voyants
c'est qu'une caricature quand même de la
grande tradition chrétienne
celui qui impose les mains d'abord c'est
l'évêque se sont pas les voyants il y a
et puis même si le sacerdoce et qu'elles
soient mal utilisées le l'objectif de
l'ordination avec le geste de
l'imposition des mains c'est quand même
envoyé pour diffuser la bonne nouvelle
du salut temps dit la ja j'avoue que je
ne vois pas ce que peut signifier cette
ce geste des mains par les voyants si je
pose les mains c'est parce que les gens
l'exigent
vous savez les gens savent que j'ai été
malade ils savent à quel point j'ai
souffert ils ont l'impression que si je
leur ai posé mais ils vont se sentir
mieux alors si quelqu'un me demande de
lui imposer les mains je ne vais pas
dire que je ne peux pas le faire c'est
normal de le faire au nom de la vierge
mais moi je n'ai pas le pouvoir de faire
des miracles en revanche dieu lui fait
des miracles et utilise les gens parfois
pour faire ces miracles
on a été le couple ensemble à voir et
nous imposer les mains en reste un jeu
ou celle du mari on a communiqué avec 6
c intérieurement c'est l'époque belgrade
c'est des forces qui fait car on arrive
dans la ville après dans le public les
gens ne regardent plus voit le sourire
parce que le sourire de mail c'est ce
que parmi les six voyant trois d'entre
eux continuent chaque jour de voir la
vierge
le phénomène a lieu à domicile comme ici
chez maria cette jeune femme mère de
trois enfants a aménagé chez elle cette
petite chapelle pour accueillir les
pèlerins
d'après maria c'est à 18h40 précise que
marie lui apparaît
china chic et sinan abc m'a souhaité
elle restera dans cette position pendant
plus de trois minutes
en 1985 et 1998
deux équipes de chercheurs catholiques
françaises et italiens ont étudié
scientifiquement le déclenchement des
apparitions chez les voyants de
medjugorje une première mondiale en
matière de recherche
psychophysiologiques sur des voyants ils
ont posé des électroencéphalogrammes ils
ont analysé leur sensibilité à la
douleur leur rythme de respiration leur
fréquence cardiaque
les scientifiques en ont conclu qu au
moment précis du début de l'apparition
les voyant entrer effectivement dans un
état modifié de conscience qu'on appelle
l'extase c'est l'hypnose et kenneth
starr et soviets en substance lors que
ce soit en hypnose ou en extase
si nous piquons le sujet il ne répond
plus la stimulation externe
idem ou bien un faisceau de lumière
intense dans les yeux c'est cela le
passage modifié il sujet ne répondent
plus aux stimulus externe et aucune
lésion de ce produit par exemple les
yeux qui sont exposés à une lumière
intense pendant l'extase ne présente pas
de lésions contraire de quelqu'un qui
regarde le soleil alors qu'il est en
état de veille normal
physiquement quelqu'un qui est temps et
ça se ressemble à quelqu'un qui n'est
pas en extase à ceci près que si on le
touche
a priori la moindre réaction les yeux
sont elles généralement fixe mais
quelquefois les yeux peuvent battre et
dans d'autres cas on a remarqué que les
yeux pouvaient nos contrées ne pas
signer pendant des périodes
extraordinaire qui sera absolument
impossible à tenir pour quelqu'un qui
sera en état normal
aïe
même si les voyants sont en extase s'ils
sont mentalement ailleurs la science ne
peut pas prouver la réalité de
l'apparition ni la présence de marie
toutefois une chose est sûre parmi les
six voyant de medjugorje
il y à au moins un simulateur qui ne
voient rien ni vierge marie ni même
représentation mentale de celle ci mais
qui copient les autres depuis le début
le secret médical interdit aux médecins
de révéler son identité
je suis assez suspicieux devant ces gens
qui peuvent voir la vierge à 18h40
depuis 15 ans ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui à partir du moment
où ils sont sur un certain registre
continue à se situer sur ce registre
qu'à partir mans on pourrait dire où les
voies neurologiques se sont créés en
fait elle fonctionne donc on peut
supposer que quelque part à partir du
moment où la personne s'est mis en état
d'être visionnaire où il reproduit d'une
manière quasiment rituel le contexte
c'est-à-dire un office religieux une
foule priait de priant et priant selon
un certain registre le phénomène peut se
reproduire
dans l'ensemble des autres religions on
s'aperçoit que le phénomène de
l'apparition le phénomène de la
révélation est quasiment un phénomène
courant et que c'est le au contraire les
monothéismes qui les ont extrêmement
réduit je veux dire le chaman lui des
apparitions il en a pratiquement trois
ou quatre par semaine
c'est normal c'est normal c'est au
contraire chez nous que les apparitions
sont les plus rares parce que dans le
monothéisme
on considère qu'il ya un fossé entre le
dieu est la créature du coup le
phénomène d'apparition devient quand
même je dirais très très facilement
suspect et on se demande toujours si
d'une certaine manière ce n'est pas une
ruse du diable
à plusieurs reprises
l'évêque de la région de medjugorje a
mis en doute l'origine surnaturel de ses
apparitions
mais rien n'interdit un fidèle de se
rendre sur un lieu d'apparition présumés
même s'il n'est pas reconnu et les
frères franciscains qui dirige la
paroisse les villageois et les voyants
ont tout fait pour attirer les pèlerins
malgré les mises en garde répétées de
l'évêque salir en inde dans un moment où
les chrétiens finalement se sont donné
le droit à eux même de juger eux-mêmes
ce qui est vrai et ce qui n'est pas vrai
ce qui leur convient ce qui leur
convient pas jean paul ii peut dire
absolument ce qu'il veut sur ce qu'il
veut qu'on n'écoute pas les effets qu on
ne les on ne les écoute pas look lui
depuis quelques siècles l'église
catholique est toujours très hésitante
avant de se prononcer sur l'origine
divine d'une apparition de la vierge au
xxème siècle sur plus d'un millier
d'apparition recensé l'église en a
reconnu seulement une dizaine la
dernière reconnaissance officielle date
de 1987 c'était au venezuela
marié esperanza medrano de bianchini et
la seule personne dont les apparitions
actuels sont authentifiés par l'église
catholique depuis près de vingt ans
comme la vierge le lui aurait demandé
marié esperanza parcourt le continent
américain pour délivrer des messages
d'espoir elle prêche l'amour du prochain
la famille la réconciliation entre les
peuples fille d'un riche homme
d'affaires vénézuélien marié esperanza
aurait vu la vierge pour la première
fois dans les années 30
à l'âge de 12 ans marie lui serait
apparue pour la console et la guérir
d'une grave maladie plus tard marié
esperanza devenue religieuse à une autre
apparition sainte-thérèse lui aurait
demandé de quitter le couvent est
d'aller à rome trouver un mari
de fait dans la capitale italienne
elle rencontra géo bianchini un ancien
garde militaire du vatican qui lui donna
six filles un garçon et 20
petits-enfants
au début des années 70 la vierge lui
aurait demandé d'acheter une terre où
elle pourrait lui apparaître de nouveau
c'est donc ici entre ces feuillages au
lieu-dit bethanien à 50 km au sud de
caracas que marié esperanza dit avoir vu
la vierge le 25 mars 1976
ce jour la fête de l'annonciation marié
esperanza méditait avec 30 personnes sur
la vie du christ lorsqu'elle a perçu
marie autour d'elle personne n'a rien vu
la santé c'est ma ville quand j'ai vu la
vierge marie venir comme ça
avec l'enfant jésus dans ses bras comme
s'il voulait m'en faire cadeau me le
donne et gelé d'abord vu seuls les bras
tendus devant mais après j'ai vu
l'enfant comme s'il voulait me donner
je n'ai jamais voulu parler de ça a des
montagnes parce que c'est un mouvement
très intime pour moi c'est un moment
sacré s'en souvenir
c'est la plus belle chose de ma vie ok
parce que son sourire et sa dette est
gravé dans mon âme c'est mal mais on
sent le sourire tout et temples et ses
yeux merveilleux sens gravé dans mon âme
plus tard mari lui aurait délivré des
messages
la vierge s'est présenté comme la
réconciliatrice des peuples et des
nations
venu sauver ce 20ème siècle marqué par
les guerres et le mal si chacun ne se
convertit pas rapidement aurait dit la
vierge les hommes périront par les
flammes
ou la madone l'accaparent une madone qui
apparaît doit nécessairement parler de
quelque chose qui ne va pas la présence
de la madone c'est ça si tous dans
l'histoire filer droit si on peut dire
ce nous n'aurions pas besoin d'une
présence mariale quelque chose qui ne va
pas rend légitime la présence de marie
le dimanche 25 mars 1984 huit ans jour
pour jour après la première apparition
marie esperanza avait invité ses enfants
des amis ainsi que de vagues
connaissances à venir prier avec elle à
bethanien
ce jour là le 25 mars 1984 toutes les
personnes présentes affirmé avoir vu la
vierge
l'apparition s'est produite là-bas dans
le tunnel dans le tunnel entre les
feuilles
c'était en 1984 son visage était parfait
elle se balançaient entre les feuilles
là-bas entre les deux arbres merci
vierge marie
je me rappelle que nous étions tous en
bas en train de discuter de manger et
tout à coup un groupe d'enfants qui
étaient restés à jouer au ballon en
phase dans la grotte est descendu en
courant vers nous en criant ils étaient
effrayés impressionné et un des enfants
criaient je n'oublierai jamais maman
fantôme aux fantômes
lorsque nous sommes montés à la grecque
nous avons vu au dessus de la chute d'où
la très sainte vierge
on pouvait voir une silhouette blanche
une femme vêtue de blanc qui se tenait
là debout quand nous avons vu nous
sommes tous dit c'est probablement
claqué un reflet puisqu'il y avait
plusieurs plantations de bananes nous
pensions qu'il pouvait s'agir d'un
reflet sur l'une des feuilles non mais
qu à la malraux à café on n'a pas le
droit je suis sûr qu'il s'agissait d'une
apparition réelle n'était pas le reflet
du soleil sur les feuilles phénomène dû
à l'humidité
voilà que lui okola ue y est ils ont mal
impressionné le plus impressionnant
c'était la façon dont ce format d'image
c'était vraiment impressionnant et nous
regardent alors nous sommes restés là la
regarder stupéfait mais tu sais toujours
avec ce doux typique de l'esprit humain
en nous demandant et comment est ce
possible
et soudain elle a fait volte face et les
disparus alors nous étions tous surpris
mais lorsque nous nous sommes rendu
compte que nous avions douter nous avons
ressenti une grande douleur parce que
nous allions douter de la véracité du
phénomène puis tout d'un coup un nuage
s'est formée et la vierge est apparue de
nouveau il y avait brisé son voile
bougeait fait son manteau bougeait et
ensuite elle a même ri et il y a eu un
moment où elle nous a salués
elle faisait comme ça on avait
l'impression d'une toute jeune fille de
14 15 ans puis après on a vu les cheveux
tombant sur les épaules elle était très
belle
la vision à plusieurs ou l'apparition
plusieurs c'est une question qui est
donc à mon avis tout à fait intéressante
à élaborer et mon explication à moi
c'est ce qu'on appelle la contagion
effective il y à un éthologue bien connu
qui a montré que les émotions pouvait se
transmettre à la vitesse d'une traînée
de poudre dans une population animale
bon on peut dire que par exemple dans un
match de foot les émotions se dirait
traverse la foule et se propage dans la
foule d'une manière extraordinaire se
dire qu'à partir man 2 ans dans une
foule
on ne s'appartient pas totalement se
dire qu'on on fonctionne à l'unisson et
un certain nombre de phénomènes qu'on
appelle paranormaux qui sont directement
liés à ce fonctionnement harmonique des
personnalités l'une en face de l'autre
c'est dire qu'en fait les cerveaux
fonctionnant à l'unisson peuvent
percevoir donc les mêmes images à
l'identique
tous
la semaine suivant l'apparition 108
personnes ont témoigné directement
auprès de l'évêque de lost et caisses
titulaire d'un doctorat de psychologie
piot bello ricardo est vrai qu'à
l'époque des faits amenez-le enquête sur
ce cas presque unique dans l'histoire
plus de 100 personnes dans un état de
conscience normale affirment avoir vu la
vierge apparaître et disparaître cette
fois durant la même après-midi
il n'a pas été difficile de déterminer
le sens critique des témoins de
l'apparition
car dans la propriété de bethanien lors
des apparitions il n'y a pas eu de ce
domaine d'extase lorsque les ont vu
l'apparition elles ne sont pas tombés en
externe comme ce fut le cas par exemple
du bernadette à lourdes où les petits
enfants à fatima
pour l'évêque l'absence de tout extase
est un critère positif et selon lui
l'apparition collectif du 25 mars 1984
n'est pas une hallucination l'éveil de
lost et caisse a jugé seul il en avait
le droit
pour étudier une apparition le vatican a
mis en place une procédure dans les
années 70
il s'agit d'un document de quatre pages
strictement confidentielles écrit en
latin est envoyée aux évêques en cas
d'apparition dans leur diocèse
ce n'est donc ni le pape ni le vatican
qui jugent de l'origine surnaturel d'une
apparition
c'est toujours l'évêque du diocèse libre
à lui de consulter ou pas des experts et
des médecins je pense que le problème
des apparitions et des révélations n'a
pas été étudiée de manière les normes
actuellement en vigueur date encore de
1974 tiennent en deux ou trois pages et
reste encore discrète
elles n'ont encore jamais été publié
elles sont remises aux évêques
lorsqu'ils sont face à un cas de façon
les aiguiller mais je pense qu'étant
donné la fréquence des apparitions au
cours de ces dernières décennies
l'église ferait bien de repenser
systématiquement à ces questions
peut-être des problèmes plus importants
mais il serait bon que cette question
soit examinée de façon plus critique est
plus adaptée à notre temps
en conséquence après avoir étudié avec
acharnement les apparitions de la vierge
marie dans la propriété bethania et
avoir fréquemment demandé au seigneur de
m'accorder le discernement spirituel
clark à mon avis ses apparitions sont
automatiques et ont un caractère
surnaturel
selon le dogme catholique
la reconnaissance officielle n'est pas
une garantie absolue et chaque chrétien
est libre de croire ou non aux
apparitions reconnu comme lourdes
fatima ou bethanien après la
reconnaissance officielle
marié à esperanza à céder son terrain à
l'église depuis 1984 plus d'un millier
de personnes disent avoir vu la vierge
dans la grotte de bethanien mais seuls
mariés esperanza affirme l'avoir entendu
et
marié esperanza est considéré par
certains comme une des plus grandes
mystiques du xxème siècle comme de
nombreux saints dans l'histoire du
catholicisme est là les stigmates mais
aussi d'autres phénomènes étranges est
rarissime sur lesquels l'église ne se
prononcent pas
olé des phénomènes très particulier font
partie de la personnalité spirituelle de
maria espérances
par exemple elle a le don de lévitation
c'est à dire qu'elles s'élèvent vie
quitte le sol
l'api location c'est à dire qu'elle
était vue en des endroits où ils
n'étaient pas et ceci à plusieurs
occasions
et le phénomène à mon sens le plus
remarquable c'est que de sa poitrine
jaillit une ruse ferait une rose fraîche
qui pousse de l'intérieur de sa poitrine
c'est lui en des douleurs les plus
horribles
je vous dis moi qui est retouchée de cet
enfant j'ai la poitrine qui gonfle c'est
épouvantable d'abord c'est un beau taux
minuscule qui sort et peu à peu le
bouton s'ouvre et puis de petites
feuilles apparaissent et même une tige
c'est extrêmement fort cuando servi va
quand on découvre qu'une voyante a en
plus derrière elle tout un passé de
révélations de phénomènes mystique ou
para mystique la sphère est encore plus
compliquée comment faire pour tout
vérifier
quand les phénomènes deviennent un peu
folklorique si c'est dieu qui procure
tout ce folklore ou si cela ne provient
pas plutôt de la nature
il ya une petite lumière là bas on
dirait comme une croix c'est beau c'est
joli cette petite lumière dans la forêt
elle s'en vient elle s'en vient c'est
elle
elle est tellement un radar cette femme
que ça pose des questions je crois
qu'elle est à elle a vraiment un lien
avec le ciel mais son côté radar moi ce
serait plutôt mon objection mon coté qui
m'inquiete ray chez elle rien eu si je
dis que je me méfie c'est parce que les
gens qui ont ça va ils peuvent se
fabriquer des divisions et je dirais
même ce sera ça peut être leurs
problèmes quotidiens romands j'estime
beaucoup elle est enceinte femmes
oh
allez
et
oh
bleu
je verrai deux motifs qui poussent des
foules à se rendre sur les lieux
d'apparition marc est le premier motif
c'est une carence de l'église catholique
l'église mon église ne s'est
véritablement pas présenter le dieu de
la libération
le dieu de la résurrection d'une manière
attractive et chaleureuse si on va sur
les lieux de pèlerinage c'est quand même
avant de voir l'aspect pénitentiaire on
veut trouver une chaleur de proximité
les gens faire feu dieu est alors
souvent ils ne trouvent pas là où il est
ça leur paraît wsop à l'abstrait naji
certain effort la détruire est très
abstraite l'ernée des femmes aussi
pour les gens de la vierge c'est plus
concret est un un être de chair et de
sang
c'est une mère beaucoup de gens sont
allés mais ils savent que par elles au
moins ils sont témoins
on a chacun nos blessures du passé
on est toutes y ont grandi quand on
traîne les blessures des événements des
situations d expérience moi ce que je
peux dire c'est que en moi ce qui
manquait c'était la présence réelle de
maman marie pour pour vrai mon cas
j'avais pu me goût à la vie jamais
découragé il va pas de dépression et à
décourager la bonne solution
un moment donné j'étais j'ai crié au
secours j'étais dans un église puis en
avant de saint sacrement jeu le seigneur
ce existent leur avec toi puis la vierge
maman marie pour moi un très très
important depuis quelques années
a pris beaucoup de place dans ma vie
j'ai toujours vu la fois mais c'est elle
qui m'a pris plus à retourner vers midi
à retourner plus vers ces valeurs là
j'avais la foi mais c'était pas le
centre de ma vie
puis malgré tout le cheminement que je
faisais je n'arrivais pas à sentir la
paix et le bonheur intérieur
on a l'impression vous préférez la
vierge à votre mère oui je m'excuse mama
bâ parce que parce que ma mère c'est
selon à me donner et vit dans un sens
mais c'est le seigneur qui est passé
entre nous on est là pour procréer le
seigneur et leur tour cri du vélo pour
créer l à me donner la vie mais
elle est humaine mais
son amour est pas parfait comme le mien
pour parfum envers mes enfants ou envers
elle non plus maryse peut tout lui
confisque eux
je veux ma balle donnée complètement à l
chose que je peux pas faire avec maman
parce qu'elle est une chose que mes
enfants peuvent pas faire avec nous
malgré tout l'amour que j'ai pour vous
oui
ce qui est manifeste dans la genèse le
développement et le succès la croyance
aux apparitions de la vierge puisque
historiquement et dure depuis 1500 ans
c'est le fait que ce soit une figure
féminine qui incarne quelque chose du du
lien nécessaire que les hommes
entretiennent que les hommes du
christianisme entretiennent entre le
ciel et la terre
voir la vierge c'est en quelque sorte
accéder à la manifestation du visage
humain de dieu en quelque sorte on peut
dire que que ce visage féminin vient
adoucir
le via adoucir et en même temps montrer
quelque chose du visage de ce dieu qui
paraît aux hommes bien inaccessible
le dieu qui nous a été inculqué la
plupart du temps est un dieu masculin et
l'église qui prétend le servir et qui le
sert en tant qu'il est machiste
l'église a toujours eu ça commence très
tôt avec les pères de l'ailé père des
premiers siècles l'église a toujours eu
un mépris de la femme
la théologie savante a clairement
tranché en disant même si elle est la
mère de dieu
ce n'est quand même qu'une femme et lui
effectivement qui n'est pratiquement pas
comparable à aucune autre le miracle de
l'immaculée conception etc
mais c'est une femme il est évident que
dans le sentiment populaire la vierge
c'est une déesse
je n'ai pas vu mais je l' ai senti je me
suis senti porté
je me suis sentie bercy oh
hanine par la soul est un footeux
volonté
les gens qui font beaucoup de pèlerinage
sont des gens qui sont asphyxiés dans
leur foi ils savent que leur foi c'est
important
et puis ils sont dans un monde où la
fouettent irrespirable tout par le
contrat lors ils ont un petit signe de
dieu le riz se jette là dessus comme
quelqu'un d' affamer se jette sur un
fumier pour ramasser un morceau de pain
on
on n'a pas besoin d' extraordinaire pour
une recette
oh
il est beaucoup plus difficile de
pratiquer la charité au jour le jour que
d'aller sur les lieux de pèlerinage
auprès des apparitions et puis d'aller à
la suite des visionnaires pour
s'extasier recevoir des impositions
demain tombé d'un repos de l'esprit des
petits cailloux qu'on ramasse
collectionner les feuilles de l'arbre
sur lequel la vierge et pause et c'est
ça c'est pas de la charité
ce sont des rituels magiques
le pouvoir que détient la technologie
dans notre vie est telle que certains
ont commencé à penser que ce que les
êtres humains ne peut voir avec les yeux
la photographie elle peut lui capté
ainsi s'est produit cette chose étrange
les gens et pèlerins se rendent sur les
lieux d'apparition et prennent des
photos
il ne voit rien mais pense que lorsqu
ils donneront leur pellicule à
développer quelque chose apparaîtra et
ceci se produit dans tous les lieux
d'apparition
on
ça existe et c'est vraiment si nous
possédions une seule photo prouvant
l'existence de la madone alors nous
aurions définitivement éliminé du
l'histoire humaine la religion
chrétienne parce que nous aurions donné
la preuve de la foi dans un laboratoire
scientifique
ce ne serait plus le pape qui aurait le
dernier mot dans le christianisme mais
ce serait un prix nobel
un scientifique
l'apparition et quelques parades main in
explorables pour les sciences les
sciences habituel
la science peut dire des choses sur la
sur l'apparition en tant que matière cyr
par exemple la guérison les phénomènes
matériel de l'apparition
elle peut dire des choses sur les
aspects psychologiques les circonstances
de la parution
les locaux ainsi qu'aux logique de
l'apparition mais ne peut pas se lancer
dans la ce qu'on appelle la réalité
l'apparition à ne peut rien dire sur la
réalité de la vierge et des choses
équivalente
da il s'agit de domaines qui sont soit
du registre par normal ceux du registre
de la foule
comme un lego viendra ce serait si grand
si doux si tendre si généreux si noble y
tellement vrai tellement profond
pourquoi simplement n'est-il pas encore
venu je sens qu'ils se dénoncent après
tant d'années maintenant la vierge me
dit prépare toi
je pense que marie validera d'un moment
à l'autre mais les choses de dieu sont
imprévisibles
on ne peut jamais être sûr ni du jour
les douleurs ça arrivera quand ça
arrivera
dallest
l'économie
de là
mme bello
à
oh
mon
ce